hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to speed dungeon we have no
time to explain we literally don't
because we're running a bomb through a
dungeon and if we don't make it in time
obviously we're gonna blow up and paint
the walls red with our goopy insides and
then we're never gonna see our family in
and then we're never gonna go anywhere
but either way this game is far too
insane to explain it all and I'm too bad
at these type of games to tolerate this
with anything I can't even talk today it
has been a long day a very long day for
me so I hope you all are ready to be
patient with me as I get through this
game now I don't know how many levels
there I know that I found this game on
games old in one of those intriguing
little games with a great soundtrack ah
bass bloated okay
so I died into a million pieces hasn't
happened for it all ever no way Wow
but either way I'm I need to tone it
back a little bit because I'm starting
this game just a little bit too crazily
you stay off your rocker there I'm gonna
make it through and you're not gonna
stop me from getting to the end of you
oh god what am I supposed to do here oh
it's a goddamn puzzle ah but I for you
whoo I made it okay no problemo
everybody yay the next part is
impossible you say oh that doesn't seem
very impossible this doesn't seem hard
at all contrary to popular belief I may
actually be pretty good at games maybe
maybe not oh yeah you thought you could
defeat me you thought you could Evi me
I'm far too bro hope inhibitor will trim
buddy-buddy with him drove over the moon
oh you're gonna be fun I can already
tell how much fun I'm gonna be having
when I play this game over and over and
over and over and over again
this isn't exactly a rage game it's just
something that's challenging and
everybody likes a good challenge but
then again I've talked about that over
and over oh why must seize your destiny
Oh blue dabu d haha oh my god I thought
I was done zou I thought I was done Yin
rings but not today not to knock which
is yada BAM
we're just Save the Children save me
save the big baby known as now oh god I
made it oh I made it
that's good that's good that's it come
on why now
yeah that's right you better pack off
this cuz you gotta later
how am i I know how well that was fun
thanks for that really glad you're here
to support me in these emotional dire
straits no no no not today not today
sonny jim how am i supposed to be able
to get through here I don't know I just
don't know it's impossible really isn't
possible isn't it oh that would have
been much easier on such highjack
commentators over at home I thinking
like Oh baby who's a guru cuz all of you
finally sound a lot like [ __ ] Claus not
gonna give me no no no not today not
today
perfect perfect perfection yes I'm the
best yeah check going in my butt
why is it your head where's the
checkpoint in my butt I've no idea but I
got a bomb on my head so that's gotta
count for something right oh you think
you can be me yeah yeah man you're
teaming up on me means you're a bigger
dick than I thought you were on out
there why did I go the long way there
oh yeah be perfect oh hi oh come on I
barely got through them okay nevermind
then I'm gonna sue okay let's calm down
for a second
calm 9th it's exploding mcdu sh yeah
yeah a beer come here I have something
to say to you in here you're beautiful
oh stop it stop it I need to go I need
to go now
do not like you Oh grace oh I love you
okay you're the worst I hate you and
everything that you do oh yeah kill all
the animals that's what I have to say
about that just destroy ecosystem ring
pain and suffering to the rainforest do
bad things
ah ah I got you now Jake boy at least
they're giving me checkpoints in the
timely oh I'm so good at games oh look
at me go oh I'm the best better how do I
prove more okay did I do it
oh no no then I got a blow okay Wow god
damn that game was fun for as hectic as
it was it was a lot of fun I enjoyed
myself even though I may not have seen
so I think I may have told everyone to
kill all the animals I'd attract that
statement no one use that out of context
in some sort of a song remake remix
please don't do that so anyway if you
want to play this game links in the
description as always and it is down
there trust me it is sometimes I forget
but almost always it'll be down there so
check real close either way thanks again
everybody for watching check out my
other gigantic playlist of awesome games
that I've done in the past and as always
I will see you in the next video
Oh